[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue aux
débrief des questions au gouvernement
40 milliards d'euros de subventions
européennes pour la france l'accord
obtenu aux forceps à bruxelles est un
succès majeur il faut absolument le
valoriser tel était le mot d'ordre pour
les ministres et les députés de la
majorité aujourd'hui écoutés l'europe
s'occupe de nous l'europe vient nous
protéger oui l'accord qui a été trouvé
cette nuit est un immense succès nous
voyons l'avènement d'un jour nouveau
pour la construction européenne
ce qui s'est passé cette nuit là
renaissance européenne dans ce contexte
bien sûr dès qu'un député de
l'opposition voit les choses
différemment
les ministres montent au créneau
regarder cette séquence votre propagande
grandiloquente parle de jour historique
je vous réponds avec réalisme c'est une
faillite tragique pendant que les
dirigeants européens font les marchands
de tapis
nos concitoyens n'ont toujours pas vu le
début de long de cette soi-disante
europe qui protège
il y a un plan de relance de 750
milliards d'euros
il y à 390 milliards d'euros de
subventions et vous vous appelez ça un
échec
j'appelle ça une avancée historique
avec vous l'avez sans doute aperçu un
jean luc mélenchon qui fulminait sur son
banc le président des députés de la
france insoumise a même quitté
l'hémicycle en pleine séance direction
la salle des quatre colonnes juste
derrière moi c'est là que se trouvent
les journalistes et devant les caméras
eh bien il a donné sa version de cet
accord européen mentir aux gens en leur
faisant croire qu'on a remporté un grand
succès et que l'europe serait plus
solidaire qu'avant et bien c'est un acte
qui est tout à fait condamnable ce n'est
pas bien de mentir comme ça il pourrait
dire j'ai eu des difficultés c'était
impossible d'y arriver mais pourquoi
raconter que nous français nous y
gagnons nous ne gagnons rien personne ne
gagne rien dans cette histoire à part
les soi disant pays frugaux dont je
répète que ce sont des pays où radin ou
voyou pour certains d'entre eux et qu'il
ne faut pas les appeler autrement
une autre séquence que nous avons
sélectionné pour vous cette semaine elle
concerne cette fois le projet de loi
bioéthique cela comprend notamment la
pma pour toutes ce projet de loi il va
revenir à l'assemblée la semaine
prochaine pour une deuxième lecture dans
l'hémicycle la députée les républicains
annie genevard a remarqué que le premier
ministre avait été étonnamment discret
sur ce sujet depuis sa prise de fonction
elle a voulu l'interroger mais vous
allez le voir elle n'a pas eu
l'interlocuteur espérer monsieur le
premier ministre
j'attends que vous répondiez vous ne
pouvez pas vous dérobez vous êtes le
chef de la majorité c'est pourquoi je
vous le demande solennellement et ma
question est simple
quel est votre avis votre avis sur ce
texte
merci la parole est à monsieur olivier
verrey ministre des solidarités et de la
santé attendez
cesser ces enfantillages je vous signale
que le gouvernement répond par la voix
du ministre qu'il choisit lui même c'est
la règle s'applique en tout temps et à
tout le monde
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
et lui seul a la parole
vous l'aurez constaté je ne suis pas le
premier ministre je comprends que cela
vous attriste ce n'est donc toujours pas
aujourd'hui que nous aurons la vie de
jean castex sur ce projet de loi c'est
tout pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un autre débrief
des questions au gouvernement
[Musique]